[Musique]
une rumeur persiste depuis plusieurs
mois à Valcourt les travailleurs
mexicains seraient beaucoup moins payés
à l'usine de la multinationale BRP que
leur confrères québécois
un enjeu qui est même venu à l'oreille
de ce chargé de projet d'un organisme
communautaire qui accompagne les
nouveaux arrivants
[Musique]
on a pu parler à un travailleur qui est
confirmé que en fait oui ils étaient
payés en pesos les organismes n'avaient
jusqu'ici pas réussi à obtenir de
produits crit face aux rumeurs
persistantes Radio-Canada a enquêté
nous avons eu des entretiens
téléphoniques avec 5 travailleurs qui
sont à l'emploi des usines BRP ou
Mexique ils avaient tous accepté de
travailler à Valcourt pendant quelques
mois pour prêter main forte à leurs
collègues en raison de la rareté de la
main d'oeuvre
leur paraît alléchante BRP leur propose
40% de plus que ce qu'il gagne au
Mexique
mais même avec cette augmentation le
montant sur leur talon de paix 4 fois
moins élevé que celui de leurs collègues
québécois qui font exactement le même
travail à l'usine de Valcourt les
salaires commencent à 23 dollars l'heure
[Musique]
3D 5 travailleurs nous ont fourni des
talons de paix qui nous ont permis
d'estimer un salaire à l'heure variant
de 5 dollars 50 à 7 dollars et 25 soit
moins que le salaire minimum légal en
vigueur ou Québec leur salaire était
versé en pesos mexicain par leur usine
du Mexique
selon cet avocate personne ne peut être
payé sous le salaire minimum au Québec
même s'il s'agit de travailleurs d'une
même multinationale
une licence là le fait d'avoir des
mouvements inter-entreprises pour
pouvoir embaucher des gens du cheap
lever des gens moins chers que ce qu'on
paierait au Québec
invité à réagir BRP a commencé par nier
les allégations
et nous a ouvert les portes de son usine
on n'est pas fondé Macron vécu qu'on ne
respectait les lois applicanes le
directeur des ressources humaines
explique que les Mexicains reçoivent
moins d'argent puisqu'ils sont
entièrement pris en charge par
l'entreprise il dit que BRP prélève
environ 60% de leur salaire pour couvrir
les frais d'hébergement de transport de
repas de divertissement d'habillement et
d'assurance donc ce que vous voyez sur
le talon de paie mexicain c'est le
résiduel qui correspond environ 40% de
la rémunération il affirme que
l'entreprise procède ainsi par souci
d'équité envers les travailleurs
québécois sont les prend pas les
déductions tel quel on n'est pas
équitable envers notre travailleur
Canadiens qu'on connaît que nos
travailleurs canadiens nous employés
canadiens qui paient leur logement il
assume personnellement beaucoup de
besoins de base
impossible de confirmer le montant exact
des déductions qui n'apparaissent sur
aucun talon de paix obtenu par
Radio-Canada pour des raisons techniques
en fait mettre les déductions sur le
talon de paiement
de feuille avec un consentement en
expliquant chacune des déductions aux
employés brpa refusé de nous transmettre
ce contrat si on se fie aux informations
de BRP le 60% prélevé correspondrait à
environ 550 dollars par semaine soit un
peu plus de 2000 dollars par mois c'est
avocate comprend mal ce qui peut
justifier une déduction d'une telle
ampleur d'autant plus que la loi prévoit
qu'un employeur ne peut prélever plus de
60 dollars par semaine pour couvrir les
repas et l'hébergement je comprends
l'aspect du logement mais pour les
déductions en fait c'est clair dans la
Loi sur les normes qu'on a le droit avec
le consentement de l'employé
voilà selon cette logique une forte
proportion du montant prélevé serait
donc utilisé pour le divertissement le
transport les assurances et les
vêtements si je comprends bien des
divertissements vêtements et assurance
je vois pas où on peut leur facturer
autant d'argent que ça 550 dollars de
déduction par semaine par paix est loin
d'être la norme pour les travailleurs
étrangers temporaires on peut s'attendre
à avoir des frais qui peuvent être de
l'ordre peut-être de 300 400 dollars par
mois maximum
un peu plus de 25 travailleurs mexicains
seraient toujours à l'usine de Valcourt
la cnesst a ouvert une enquête
ibrp assure collaborer
[Musique]